hey guys merry here and do numbers
confuse you because you're gonna love
this news update it looks like Microsoft
is going to be reporting Xbox one
numbers differently moving forward
Microsoft did not share a new Xbox one
shipment number during their earnings
announcement on Thursday as it so
happens this was on purpose moving
forward Microsoft will focus more on
xbox live users ship numbers instead of
how many consoles have been shipped in
its briefing Thursday Microsoft
announced the Xbox Live had 39 million
active users in the latest quarter up
twenty-eight percent year-over-year an
active user is defined as someone who
has signed in to xbox live in the past
month in a post-earnings financial call
microsoft CEO satya nadella added that
about half of all xbox one owners log in
to xbox live every day revenue generated
from xbox live rose seventeen percent
compared to same quarter last year
microsoft said this was driven by more
total transactions as well as higher
revenue per transaction this isn't to
say that Microsoft is totally doing away
with talking about console shipment
numbers only that it will place a
greater emphasis on engagement with Xbox
Live we've been told Microsoft sees this
as a way to more accurately measure
engagement with the Xbox ecosystem for
Microsoft's latest quarter total revenue
from Hardware fell by seventeen percent
compared to last year Microsoft
attributed this downturn mainly to fewer
xbox 360 consoles sold by comparison
during the same period last year
Microsoft shipped 2.4 million combined
xbox one and 360 consoles as an active
Xbox Live user I'm flattered that
they're using me at all in their
quarterly reports for the latest on xbox
and everything gaming you're in the
right place